hello believe nations welcome to another
edition of the Evan Carmichael show i am
your host Evan Carmichael I believe it
entrepreneurs and this shows all of us
turn in your business and turning your
dream into a success I'm super excited
to be back it's been a while since my
last show I went on a vacation to Disney
World with the fam and just got back and
i'm in a new time slot it messed me up I
was dialing in at 11 I was all excited
to go for the show and ago i still have
another hour when i show up super
excited to have my old producer daniela
pasture to this episode amazing the word
with you again and welcoming my new
producer Shanna in for guest appearance
today's the first time working together
some super pumped about that as well
hello guys so today it's look important
I so what I want to talk about managing
your time time management is one of the
biggest issues that entrepreneurs face
you know we're working 1800 hour weeks
trying to get our businesses off the
ground and you guys know for those of
you who have a business and are
listening you know how hard it is to run
a company and it's one of the hardest
things you ever going to do in your life
and hopefully also one of the most
rewarding and what I found was I was
doing so much work would have been so
many hours and was getting frustrated
with not getting the results that I was
looking for you know everything I've
done up to that point in my life before
surround my first business I knew if I
put more time in it I get more results
and here was putting all this time and
energy in and I'm not getting results
what's happening it's the biggest lock
on your self confident in your prime so
then I discovered a few secrets a huge
secret the time management that really
helped change my life and change my
business and today's show is all about
sharing that with you and hopefully you
can take some of those lessons back and
apply to your schedule and your business
to start achieving more results all
right let's get to the tips the first
one that I why share is called chunking
your time okay the magic solution to
doing all the same tasks that you're
currently doing but spending the half
the time doing them is jumping your time
and the idea behind chunky
if you do common tasks together instead
of as they arise see a lot of Oxford's
and local entrepreneurs we're just in
default reaction mode you know somebody
sends a mini in Los ends up an email
response somebody called us to respond
and we're constant just jumping from one
thing to another and putting out fires
and it doesn't give us the time we need
to focus on the bigger picture stuff is
all you're doing is running around
putting out fires and you don't have
time to focus on that big stuff but
you're never going to build a highly
successful business so you have to chunk
of time and what I mean by that is
anything that you do multiple times per
day I want you to do once per day so
think about email instead of being
distracted all day long by email to
email one per day NE tak you're used to
doing multiple times per week you do
once per week so example could be
needing people if you have meetings
instead of running all over your city
meeting people after person after person
and leaving all that time in travel have
it all on one day per week and then if
you need in local times per month you do
once per month so when you get the
picture some people now you know and
this may be you some people pride
themselves on being multitaskers right
like it's a badge of honor to be a
multitasker and I used to be me right
exactly I could do I could take it all
on give it to me I'm going to work hard
I got it all but the thing is
multitasking it doesn't work as you give
the higher level work if you're doing
admin boring mundane easy stuff it is
easy to switch to contacts but when you
start working on the bigger picture
subject you need to do to grow your
business at higher level stop
multitasking doesn't work because you
lose too much time switching ok so I
want you to think about how you can jump
your time do multiple things and you can
be used to do multiple times per day
once a day multiple times per week once
a week it will dramatically change how
you look at your schedule and improve
your productivity I have Stacey on the
line AC where you from and how can I
help hi I'm 10 Virginia on Twitter
welcome aboard what's going on ok great
I understand the you got a real card
with look Schmidt I am
stand that close up I also understand
the only as good as the people that you
have around you I'm lucky enough to have
good people around we only have like one
employee but it was my fiancé's friend
so to make sure I don't sell my problem
as a as a business woman is being taken
seriously by the men in the workforce
I'm having a difficult time I have to
get Rick to hire contractors to do
repairs on my building because if they
see our women there I don't get the
regular prices that the men that get
everything is always the mood out of
proportion on this weekend foods are
always be read by a bagel really big
well I had to call the police to ask for
help because this guy I had minute
happiness I had contracted home I was
gonna hire him i put the better health
for a couple of people to fix my
sidewalk regret that a little at my side
rocker created a hazard where people
could trip so i wanted to get that fixed
so since Rick handed all the stuff cuz
my pipes have both he has all that stuff
got it all taken care of I thought oh
this is something that I could do Stacy
can call it I may soon then have him
come in here and flips the sidewalk well
I thought that's what I could go
unfortunately when I called this guy
called a couple and I went with the
cheapest price and that was my first
mistake there so it would with the
cheapest price and I agreed to take the
guy and let him fix the sidewalk he
called me to tell me that he couldn't
come in that day because he is really
like them so he can't welcome in the
concrete in the room and I understood
that the day that he called them it
wasn't raining should I call him back
and I told him that I was going to rain
until Sunday so you know yet another
reading of three days to actually do the
go and then I called him back I could
tell that he was drunk and he was in the
process of making a bread bag because I
heard him ask the guys that can crack
you doing some shady guys here but
but CT no insurance stuff you gave me
you can have a copper staff it's just
that I caught it with his guard down and
when I called him back to tell him about
the weather you said it working without
a bear jump over them talking about
drugs this is going to get better when
you 13 tune your mindset so you hide the
same thought when I was first getting
started I was in a woman but I thought I
was too young to be able to sell to
these guys that was 19 years old time I
sell my product that people three times
my age and and it was my mindset and it
wasn't until I realized that I gotta
stand up for myself and that I'm good at
what I do and I am a business owner and
I have to believe in myself that they
started to respect me right if you when
you respect yourself to a higher level
than other people will respect you and
you're going to have contractors who
will try to walk all over you whether
you're a woman or guy i built my own
health from scratch and i had
contractors try to blue me me and tell
me that I had no idea what I was talking
about because I wasn't in the industry
you know Nelson Mandela when he went to
prison he refused to talk to anybody
unless he acknowledged him by mr.
Mandela and the guards started calling
him mr. Mandela because he had that
self-confidence and he commanded the
respect so I'm not going to do with with
your race with your sex with your age it
can you command respect and it circuit
you respecting yourself enough you got
to increase the level of your own
respect for yourself and command that
some other people if not the disguise of
clothes and a crackhead does that have
anything to do with it I don't I'm man
as a women exist do this epithet for
women to buy a car typical players to do
as a parent it's difficult for us to get
repairs that on our properties because
we are not respected and we always will
get a different price and will be
treated differently than that is true
that as soon as I told them my business
partner is going to be a lil it then if
there's a whole different story I mean
this guy really certainly Texas
Christian y'all
I can like a nightmare for this because
I refused to let him take the job I'm
not going to bother drunk work on my
historic village I don't see you started
talking about the service call off
saying hey it's important to have good
people around you and you have that one
guy in the fiancees friend just the same
thing it's important to have good
contractors that you work with give you
a deal with douchebags whether you're a
man or a woman and so you gotta dealt
with people from your life I move on to
the people who are who are good who do
their work you know you're dealing in
shady industries and so find good
contractors is going to be a challenge
that anybody will have to face whether
you're a man or a woman thank you I
appreciate the car I happen bomb I want
to share with you what my schedule looks
like now I used to be the workaholic the
gun prided himself on being super class
2 replies email and answering phone
calls and as a result all I did was
those little tiny projects and I kept
getting distracted from the big projects
that i wanted to work on and i knew i
needed to focus on to grow my business
but it just didn't have the time that
work on it because i kept getting
interrupted by these little things so
here's what my schedule looks like now
and i want you to try to model it to
make it work for you so you can work a
little bigger ideas on monday is my get
stuff done for the weekday that's where
I have all the tasks i need to get done
for the week if it answering important
emails is planning my social media
campaign if i need to write a proposal
or answer something that's that's long
or look at a presentation that i'm
working on anything that i need to get
done for the week i do it on the monday
it's working in my business stuff that's
still a high enough level that needs to
commit my personal attention and I feel
like that helps set me up for the rest
of the week on Tuesday is my writing day
so I'm working on a book and I'm working
on my youtube videos and writing scripts
so I sit down and I'm spending the whole
day writing and it allows me to get my
time to work on those projects and I'm
not getting interrupted constantly
during the day in both of those days it
also gives me the right mindset so I
know I wake up all i have to do is
sit and do my admin stuff and do my
writing on Monday and Tuesday so you
know if I don't want to shave I don't
have to change you know I don't have to
have my extroverted personality ready to
go I don't have to jump between calls
and meetings and coming back to try to
write my book so probably not mine
threat and you wake up and you know this
is the kind of stuff that you're doing
today makes it so much easier when is
when I still my youtube videos so I'm
spending the whole day I usually make 13
videos for the week a lot of videos and
and I get ready right so now I'm shaving
I have my belief music playlist going
I'm getting pumped up and getting my
extroverted personality on and ready to
go and and I just line up the whole day
ready to do video Thursday is going to
be my radio show my public facing day my
calls my meeting everything is back to
back to box and again I'm extroverted I
normally can operated to go out and do
these things on Thursday and so that
sets me up for the week and you want to
create a schedule that looks for you
that helps you plan your day and plan
your week to get all those big picture
things done and not get bogged down by
the minutia and the little tasks okay I
want to get to the line I have Denise on
the line Denise where are you from and
how can I help I'm in portland oregon of
and then you've given me some tremendous
help in the past but i have a quick
question my whole you know my whole
business everything from my for profit
my nonprofit it's very spiritually based
and ever and i just recently starting to
understand that there's a difference
between a regular nonprofit and how its
churches set up and i'm wondering if it
might not be advantageous for me to set
up my nonprofit privileges over church
but i don't really understand the
difference so your question if you
should change the structure of your
nonprofit to get incorporated church
what's the advantage of being a church
as opposed to just a regular non profit
because we certainly have a spiritually
based message i did you know we would
qualify but it is it financial advantage
the thing with a church I'm like
watching
might go to a church what is they can be
your fiscal agent and what that means is
they can write tax with these charitable
routine I can you my charitable repeats
through your nonprofit right now only
for a donation if somebody purchases
something through are a non-profit no
because it's no different than going to
salvation army and buying something but
I don't know if there are other
privileges that we might enjoy at the
church because we do want to set up a
brick-and-mortar place where people can
come join us in our beliefs and our
lifestyle you know is it an advantage to
be a church to the post or a regular
nonprofit yeah so the biggest advantage
is going to be more on the promotion
time so if you can write your own
charitable receipts because like a lot
of people can they want to set up a
non-profit and they don't get approved
until they can't write a check with the
receipt so if somebody gives them a
donation they can't give that charitable
receipt so they might partner up with
the church that you can money to the
church and then church to the money to
them that's called being a fiscal aging
but if you can already write your own
turtle receipts and you don't need that
it's more of an emotional opportunity
and it'll be more can will the church be
willing for example to spread your
message to their congregation can they
put you in their titles that goes out at
each mass if you have a website will be
put you up on there will the the priest
preacher of the front say something
about your cause and what you're doing
you know does it help give your
organization more credibility and more
awareness if you can see you're aligned
with the church so it's more it's more
that kind of promotion marketing side of
things if they are going to help promote
you and help spread your message and not
to be a great way for you to be able
reach more people right right cool thank
you I'll look into it more because it
just seems like it might be the right
way to go for us because we're basically
selling a lifestyle so to get people to
congregate with us and understand what
about might be real plus yeah and it's a
way easier pitch to them if you wanted
them to if you wanted them to be your
fiscal agent where they're taking money
and then they're giving it to you that's
a much more complex relationship but you
know I need that comes out
all you're saying is hey I think we
might go to work together and we have
similar beliefs we have a similar
audience where the work we're trying to
do good as well maybe there's a way we
can work together and maybe you can help
promote them you can you know if you
know what the sermon is going to be the
topic is going to be for the next Sunday
Mass you can borrow my eye I'm talking
about creating my own church that
revolves around this philosophy and this
lifestyle and then running my business
through that basically instead of
through the nonprofit that we're working
with oh you want to create your own
church so right do you want to run a
church because you don't need it from a
financial point of view because you you
can already right the charitable
donation so from a good luck topical
point of view is that something that you
really want to go out there right okay
but financially I already have what I
need because i can write a check i can
write a receipt for a donation exactly I
come here and there thanks for calling
okay kick it okay secure and with all
these petitions for you entrepreneurs
listening you ought to make the big
decisions with your heart and the little
ones with the head right I'll financial
division is a little one but you can do
this because going to get more money but
the big one should we start a church you
do that because you believe inside
that's a big decision to make it of your
heart to take a stand yes I want to
start a church and so busy city with the
heart small into the head today we're
talking about time management giving you
strategies to help you get more out of
your day and I've got a special guest
with me on the line today he is the time
management chef what better get to have
on a show that we're talking about time
management in the time management chef
tour wrestling tourn welcome to the
program thank you i was so happy to join
your show welcome for it can you tell us
how can entrepreneurs create more time
in their lines it's a very good question
there are many ways to create more time
in your life but basically the best tips
that I have been using several years to
optimize is actually two
use of system and in order to use that
system I use master to-do list because
it's crucial that you have all your to
do tasks collected in one master to-do
list and the most important thing was
having a master to-do list is to of
course collect all the tasks in one list
because if you have several lists you
will lose track of the task so it's not
important to just have one list and
after you have connected all your tasks
and one led to do this you should use
the ABCDE system in order to prioritize
the tasks have you heard about that
matter Devon no I have so it's basically
first up there when you're prioritizing
your to do tasks and a task it's a past
you should complete today if not it will
would give you serious consequences be
task is a path that you should do today
if you don't complete it today it will
give you mind consequences and a feat
ask if a task that you it doesn't really
matter whether you do it today or not so
it's like whatever and d stands for
delegates those are tasks you of course
just delegate to other people and
east-central eliminate those are tasks
you'd never do so basically what you
want to do you want to identify your
most important tasks and you want to
start and complete all your a tasks
before you start on your b tasks and all
you'll spend you would start and
complete a B tasks before you start on
your feet asks if you do wake up every
day and look at your master to do it and
then assign ebc to the top yes that's
correct so I've been studying time
management for quite a long time and
I've been learning from the experts and
I've been testing this system for a long
time and I usually try to plan my
schedule a week in advance every Sunday
I look at my to do this and I just
scheduled my tasks
one weekend and in advance and then when
it comes to the next day i will also
just take a quick review after past the
night before and in the morning so
basically let's say it's let's say it's
Tuesday today and tomorrow it's
wednesday so tuesday night i will take a
brief look at my to-do list and if there
is some modifications i would just do
the changes and in the morning the first
thing in the morning after i get out of
bed and when i sit down at my desk i
would just take a brief look at my to-do
list just to make sure that if there are
any new changes in their to-do list so i
have good amount of personal curiosity
how long does it take you on the sunday
to plan your league and then how long
are you spending every morning looking
at the list and seeing where you have to
get done it's a very good question Evan
usually what I do I have this monster to
do list and I just continuously add
tasks so when I look at it apple sunday
i may use maybe not more than 30 minutes
because all the tasks are on the to-do
list so I kind of just rearrange the
importance of the tasks and then when I
look at it in the morning I've spent
maybe five to ten minutes to just review
their to-do list before I start on my
most important tasks not I mean how do
you handle and this happens a lot with
entrepreneurs have you handle the crisis
calm the the last minute thing that
changes your schedule and you know
didn't you couldn't you couldn't
forecast it from Sunday but now you've
got to deal with this thing haven't you
how do you factor that in very good
question event so absolutely although
like there will always keep continue to
continuous later full new to the set to
do tasks down in our lap all the time so
basically what I use I use the 8020 rule
to always identify the most important
task so let's say for an instance ok so
today it's Wednesday and it's 10 a.m.
and i'm working on what to do
Justin then suddenly i get an important
call or an important email and there's a
ask that I just have to do so when i get
the new task in my lap I immediately
identify it if it's an abs or C task and
if it's an a task could just have to do
a quiz gear analyze if it's more
important than my current task so I
would just put it into my plan if it's
more important that their task i'm
currently handling i'm starting on minut
the more important task it's not I'm
just scheduling it on my current list
got it what do you think is the biggest
struggle that ass foreigners have when
it comes to applying you've heard about
this I mean further than other things
they may have tried to plan a schedule
but it just doesn't work to keep falling
off track why do you know what's that
what's why should such a struggle to do
time engine I think is there are several
reasons so I think number one of another
one reason can be that they don't know
actually know what to do and number two
is that the action know what to do they
don't take action and number number
three is that they think that when it
comes to saving same time that it has to
be a big here we go like it's this big
project and that it will take way too
much time and effort to implement and
the number for the most important thing
is that the perhaps they don't have a
system that they already know is working
so what's the solution created system UD
b c d e yeah i would say that so if i
should have just go to the zoo okay
would think is the solution here yeah
overcoming that struggle I mean I'm
about Roger could probably write blogs
on time management and you know we still
juggle with it so by the time you will
come back yeah so I would say number one
it supposed to find out what to do and
number two is to actually take action
and to implement the steps so ask
Napoleon Hills us in his book think
grow fish knowledge is not power
application of knowledge is power it
doesn't matter if you have all the
knowledge in the world in a specific
area if you don't apply it and then it
comes to the number tree about the big
hairy goal it's often I think it's the
best way to approach this is to break
the big hair a goal down into smaller
goals so let's say if I said I could
help you save 180 2.5 hours each year
you think that it might sound a bit
unrealistic but what if I broke to go
down into 365 days so I said what if I
have to say certain minutes per day that
sounds more realistic right yeah and
there's nothing really quick food yeah
so 30 minutes per day if you multiply it
with 365 days it will be 180 2.5 hours
per year so if we say that the mobile
normal work with is 40 hours we can take
180 2.5 hours and just / 40 hours it
will be the total resource up for point
fifty five weeks so only saving 30
minutes per day you will actually be
able to they said get four and a half
work with more career and if you spend
that time wisely imagine what you could
do with your life in business it it's
awesome that's a lot of time that's a
lot of time to work thank you so much
for joining us for people who want to
learn more about you where can they go
yes thanks for asking they can they go
to the following website time management
chef's calm smash Ellen I would have a
free ebook which will help them to
double their productivity in seven days
time management chefs call / Ellen all
right thank you so much for joining us
tour really appreciated Ella now I've
been talking about chunking your time by
that's been the theme for this show is
anything you're doing multiple times per
day we're doing once per day multiple
times per week we're doing once per week
I'm shared my schedule not monday i'm
doing my administaff ready for the week
on tuesday i'm doing my writing that's
my goal
private video lightly I'm recording the
video seriously I'm doing meetings and
public facing stuff and radio shows and
interviews and what you want to do is
now creative schedule that works for you
anything that again you do multiple
times per day life email for example
then do that in a 90-minute chunk every
day if you need to write a check email
every day it's a 90-minute chance every
day in 90 minutes is a great amount of
time to force yourself to get it done
and be fast because let's be honest you
know you have a lot of work with your
often getting attracted you might be
getting a facebook notification and
flopping over to that you know so you
want to make sure when you only have 90
minutes to do a task then you're going
to be focused on getting it done and
being really efficient and not allow you
to get distracted so I plan all my days
out into 90 minute chunks with 15 minute
breaks in between so intense hardcore 90
minutes of work you know don't go to the
bathroom unless I have to don't get
distracted and then move on to a 15
minute break and then back into running
in the chunk and I find that really
helps me organize my day and get a lot
of stuff done and stay focused I have
time for one last caller I'm going to
hit up the lines and we have Laura on
hold more worried from and help you my
house hi I'm from outside of st. Louis
and I love what you're saying about the
90-minute test event I think I could
maybe do nine minutes with my focus
capacity but you know maybe I could
alter it a little and get something done
but my my question has to do with
entrepreneurial business partnership I'm
a water garden landscape designer and my
main contractor is kind of like my
business partner and we worked together
on bids and sales so we kind of show up
to the customer as one team sometimes
the tricky part is that his numbers in
terms of the the price he bids a job for
often makes it so that we don't get the
job the customers like me they want to
work with me but it's not in their
budget so we're
good friends we've been working together
for years but i have a friend they keep
saying you know lawyer you're doing it
wrong you need to be the general
contractor and then you need to be
hiring other contractors to give you the
best price in the bids so I'm having a
dilemma yeah and I'd be thinking what's
back to the customer you know because
you're going in and you only have one
option and they love working with you
but then they can't in for because they
don't like the price point of your the
guy you're going in with then you're
losing business and it's not in the best
interest of the customer because they
want to work with you they like you
trust you you know they like the designs
are coming up with and so it what you
would like things to go work with
somebody else just because you want this
guy and know him and we were together
for years yes there's there's just it we
just have a good strong relationship we
work well together and I do coaching
with he and his wife I work in the
business I you know sometimes I stay
there when they're either there a couple
hours from where I live so you know
there's nothing like mixing friendship
and business to have it get a little
fuzzy around the edges but it's it's
just sometimes a little challenging
because I want to be an integrity that's
important to me in the relationship and
I also would like to eat no both are
very important things yeah so I would
say first of all you have to have a
conversation right if you're considering
this then you need to have an open
conversation not because behind his back
because that's not something that you
would you to do right so he has to know
that this is something that you're
thinking about and that you might move
forward on it I think obviously if he's
bringing the deal but he's the only guy
right you're not going to swipe his
client from him some contact that he
made you know you know you're gonna sell
somebody his competitor services right
if he's bringing your engine you only
work with
but if you're getting the deal if it's
one of your contacts and networking then
you want to be able to provide whatever
the best solution is for that customer
and I feel integrity and that when that
helps feed you but it should have the
conversation with with your friend so
that you know that you're something that
you're thinking about and Samba to get
help grow your business I'll give you an
example I have a great gut in mind who
the photographer he does a lot of
celebrity photographers and pictures
gonna be lady gaga and huge celebrities
and sometimes I could bring him in on
deal that I'm working on right if
there's any video of photo involved I
can often bring your name into hey
here's an opportunity to introduce you
to rich byah but his price points are
really high too and so that not always
that I could recommend him but I thought
I was the best solution for the client
and there's no way a little needs a deal
with my clients just to bring rich in
and it's not the best thing for decline
and it's not the best thing for me
either and which totally gets that right
not he got he can't work with every kind
because of its price point so I think
you having a conversation with him and
being open and honest and don't our
clients want to work with anyway right
like they can't afford and you're losing
the deal anyway but you can work with
them and so there's a an issue you can
see still say I'm going to recommend you
but if you can't afford it then I'm
going to try to give them another option
somebody who share a little more
portable I've been done it I know I I
think that's great and it's it's you
know and the other tricky factor is that
you know six months ago or a little over
six months ago he came down with a brain
tumor and then had surgery and radiation
and so he's you know doing great doing
fine MRIs look good yes but he's just
fuzzy and so you know he needs me even
more now than what he did in the past I
know just running out of time I gotta
let you go with that but I think it's
still that he shouldn't be hurt and
shouldn't be offended if you approach it
with instead
be a friend it doesn't mean you're not
being a friend to him anymore you're
still being a friend to him but at the
same time you protecting your interest
in sleeping at the doctor at the same
time that's great you so much thank
everybody freak show we'll see you in a
month Thank You Danielle and Shannon you
guys are awesome stick to need to
believe and I'll see you soon